starting off this hours gonna be Jay in
San Diego hi Jay welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show
morning Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up in your world Oh
so recently this week found out that my
wife had kind of racked up about 40k and
credit card debt behind the scenes so
kind of just slap to the face you know I
kind of found out this week this last
weekend so it's pretty pretty tough to
swallow mmm
so she was hiding it from you yeah and I
you know I can't just blame her I mean I
got to take some credit because I never
kind of went and looked and kind of a
hating the attention and this is the
second time so about two and a half
years ago kind of the same thing and I
kind of laid out a budget and then kind
of slipped away from that budget and I
think it was it just kind of rolled back
into it I assumed everything was going
okay but it just kind of wasn't okay so
you gave her all of the responsibility
of handling the money and you weren't
involved in the money a hundred percent
okay yeah yeah it is your fault you know
yep and it's her fault but basically she
was out of control didn't know what to
do and just borrowed her way into a mess
and neither one of you had your head in
the game
correct okay so uh are y'all ready to
stop the cycle I can show you how yeah
100% and as this this week inside
there's I don't wanna say more to the
problem is that kind of a solution but
on Wednesday this week I got a I
received a $29,000 inheritance check
that I haven't put in the bank yet
because I wanted to wait till I spoke
with you to see how I go attack this I
don't want to I don't want to do any
other dumb things I want to continue I
want to start from scratch pay off the
debt but I got to do it the right way
okay well let me ask you this then it
sounds like you're taking ownership for
having kind of dumped this on your wife
and abandoned her is she taking
ownership for the
the fact she was ashamed and so she hid
this from you because she didn't know
what to do but she knew she was screwing
it up yeah we we had a couple
conversations we were a church and we
have some marriage enrichment stuff and
we got to look into doing some more that
kind of get us in fact I mean I don't
want to send a nice guy to talk to but I
think yes we've accepted responsibility
yeah I don't know that you were
necessarily hard to talk to you just
abandoned her yeah yeah just left you
left her out in the cold she was doing
the best she could and she screwed it up
really bad and was really ashamed to
tell you it sounds like that's the way
it goes the reason I'm asking and the
reason I'm poking at you a little bit is
because it changes what to do with the
29000 okay now the other possibility is
and I don't think that's what's going on
here but you tell me because I'm asking
you is the other possibility is this
woman is a deceiver she's a liar and
she's running around hiding stuff
because she's buying whatever she wants
and there's an arrogance to this not a
repentance to this I don't think I don't
think I hear that no okay
then all we got to do is commit both of
you to say never again and every time I
do something really stupid and it leaves
a big mark on me you know leaves a big
scar I always get a never again out of
it you know like never again do I do
business with American Express because
they called my wife one time when we
were going broke and asked her why she'd
stay with a man they wouldn't pay his
bills and she called me crying because
she was thinking the same thing right so
I don't do business American Express
never again never again that was 35
years ago I still remember I'm still
redneck pissed about it right so never
again never again do I borrow money
never again to you to go a single month
without both of you agreeing on the
spending and knowing where the money is
and where it's gone to the rest of your
lives both of you are managing this
company called you incorporated together
now one of you has an administrative
gift that will actually write the checks
more than the other one but the other
one whoever that and that probably is
her actually it sounds like it might be
you I don't know whoever writes the
checks I don't care but we're gonna be
in agreement on paper
on all of our spending for the rest of
our lives and we're going to pinky swear
and spit shake we're never going to
spend over five hundred dollars again
without talking to the other person ever
under any circumstances because we're
married and we'd like and we'd like to
stay that way yeah okay if you can do
that then pretty simple we'll just take
the 29,000 and start working our way out
of this mess and you guys start doing a
budget together jump on every dollar I'm
gonna sign you up for every dollar plus
I'm gonna pay for it because you guys
need to be on the same page on each of
your phones you can put on your phone
and connect it to your bank accounts and
every time they're spending it'll pop up
on each of you is phone gives you this
built-in accountability built in
agreement that the budget is being
executed as agreed and we write up the
budget on every dollar every month
before the month begins every dollar has
an assignment we decide what we're going
to do with it together and then if one
of you writes two checks that's fine but
together and we don't do anything ever
with money except what we have agreed to
on this paper this paper is a contract
before the month begins you following me
Colin if you guys will do that now who's
the nerd and who's the free spirit who's
the detail person which one of you know
you're the detail person yeah
administrative league if tada okay and
you ask the free spirit to do the gift
to do the accounting one man you double
dipped in dumb okay so you got to do
you're probably the natural person to
write the checks out you like details
she hates them right yeah so I mean yeah
if we were gonna hire someone for you
incorporated to do the accounting we
would hire you to do the accounting not
her to do the accounting and it's not a
male-female thing it's an administrative
gifting thing yep okay so yeah that's
probably what gonna be but we're both
gonna be in agreement in other words
we're not taking all of this away from
her and giving it to you to do without
her input we're not gonna swing the
pendulum the other way both of you agree
on all of your spending and let me tell
you 90 days of doing this you'll get in
a rhythm six months of doing it your
trust and your communication will be 25
fold what it is right now in your
marriage it's really going to have a
positive impact on your marriage because
Jesus said your treasures where your
heart is and when you spend your money
together
you're agreeing on your dreams you're
agreeing on your fears you're agreeing
on your values you're agreeing on your
priorities and when you're in agreement
on that it takes a great it takes a good
marriage it makes it great and I really
think you're probably you probably
probably got a pretty decent marriage or
you rode well it killed each other prep
for you called me yeah we got a great
marriage and that's what I want to look
forward to is you know keep making it
better and then doing this together and
like you said not not leaving her out to
dry no that was definitely my fault I
appreciate the poke yeah well I mean I'm
trying to figure out in that number one
I mean she screwed up to okay I closed
some on her but but I was just trying to
figure out who she is because now we
just take that 29,000 then we start
working the baby steps which means the
40 that we're gonna fly most of it to
the 40,000 and start clearing up these
credit cards and chop them all up into
little bitty pieces so hold on we'll get
you signed up give him a year of every
dollar plus okay I'm not even sure how
to do that but we'll figure it out okay
somebody knows how to do it in the
building this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]